There is a lot of water on Mars and
there once was a lot of surface flowing
water.
You don't,
uh,
you don't see it because it's,
most of it is mixed with the soil which
we call regolith on Mars.
So the Martian soil can be anywhere from
as little as one percent in some very
dry desert,
like areas to as much as 60 percent
water.
One strategy for getting water when
you're on Mars is to break up the
regolith,
which would take something like a Jack
Hammer because it's very cold.
It's very frozen.
If you can imagine making a frozen brick
or a chunk of ice that's mostly soil and
maybe half water and half soil,
that's what you would be dealing with.
So you need to break this up,
put it in an oven.
As it heats up,
it turns to steam your,
run it through a distillation to,
and you have pure drinking.
Water comes out the other end.
There is a much easier way to get water
on Mars.
Um,
in this country we have developed
industrial dehumidifiers.
Um,
and there's a very simple machines that
simply blow the air in a room or a
building across a mineral called zoo
lights.
Zeolite is very common on earth that's
very common on Mars and Zeolite is Kinda
like a sponge.
It absorbs water like crazy.
It takes the humidity right out of the
air,
then you squeeze it and outcomes the
water.
And scientists working for NASA at the
University of Washington as long ago as
19 in the 19,
late 19 nineties,
developed a machine called a waiver that
very efficiently sucks water out of the
Martian atmosphere.
So water is not nearly significant
problem that appears to be.
We also know from orbiters around Mars
and right now there are five satellites
orbiting Mars.
We know from photographs that these
orbiters have taken,
and I'm a geological studies that
they've done that.
There is frozen ice on the surface of
Mars.
Now.
There's tons of it at the polls.
Some of it is overladen with frozen or
mixed with frozen carbon dioxide.
But in many craters on Mars,
there apparently are sheets of frozen
water.
So if early astronauts are early
voyagers tomorrow's where to land near
one of those sheets of ice in a crater,
um,
they would have all the water they need.